كيف يمكن النظر لهذه الخطوه خطوه التوقيع
اتفاق اولي او اتفاق مبدئي لطرفي الازمه
السودانيه في جده كيف يمكن بناء عليه كذلك
يا هلا بك لايف
واحيي مشاهدي قناه العربيه
في الواقع الاتفاق الذي يعني بدا منذ ايام
في مدينه جده برعايه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ظل انظار كل السودانيين الذين يعملون منه
الكثير لانهاء هذه الحرب التي اندلعت بين
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني ممثل لحكومه
السودان ولدوله السودان
ومنذ الايام الماضيه كان الناس يعني
يتحسسون ما يتسرب من هذا الاجتماع المهم
جدا
واعتقد انه الوصول الى
قضايا مبدئيه توقع في هذه المرحله
امر مهم جدا
لا سيما وان قضيه معقده لابعد ابعد الحدود
طرف الجيش السوداني طبعا وهو يبدو انه قد
هيمنه بشكل اكبر على ساحات المعارك في
السودان
لا يريد ان يتخلص من هذه المعمعه الا وقد
بسط سيطرته على كل مواقع
المتمردين
ويستطيع ان يقول بعد ذلك انه قد انهى
المعركه على المستوى العسكري
رجال الدعم السريع
رغما على الظروف التي يعيشونها والتشتت
الذي حدث لهم لديهم كان الامل في ان
يحققوا نصرا ولو قليلا ولذلك تمسكوا جدا
بالقصر الجمهوري وتمسكوا بمطار الخرطوم
وتمسكوا بالقياده العامه لفتره طويله طبعا
في الاصل هم كانوا فيها يعني لم يحتلوها
اثناء المعرض طيب لما شعروا بالحكايه طبعا
دخلوا على البيوت فبالتالي الان الاتفاق
انا اعتقد مهم جدا في هذه المرحله ولا
نطمع في اكثر مما توصل اليه الان
المتحدثين ما الذي يعني يمكن ان يطمع به
السودانيون في القمه العربيه القادمه في
الرياض ما الذي يمكن ان يعولوا عليه
لمعالجه انسانيه على الاقل للوضع السوداني
الحالي دكتور
هي وضحت من خلال مؤتمر وزراء الخارجيه
العرب خلال الايام الماضيه القليله
وبالتالي التعويل كبير جدا على مؤتمر
القمه عندما يعني يلتئم الشمل بشكل كامل
لانه اساسا بدات قضيه التعامل مع السودان
والتعاطف معه وعلى راس الاشياء هو يقرار
عدم التدخل في شؤون السودان من اي طرف من
الاطراف طبعا الذي يتم الان بين امريكا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه ليست تدخل في
شؤون السودان وانما رعايه
لمؤتمر يمكن ان يرى بالصدوع ويضع لبنات
للحل الختامي في المرحله القادمه ان شاء
الله الكثير يا دكتور يتساءلون اليوم عن
دور الاتحاد الافريقي وكان له دور ايجابي
في حل كثير من القضايا العالقه والازمات
الداخليه الافريقيه الافريقيه لكن في
الازمه السودانيه هناك من ينظر بان
الاتحاد الافريقي قد تراجع دوره كثيرا
خصوصا في السودان هل تتفق دكتور مع هذا
الراي
انا اتفق مع هذا الراي ولكن اعلم السبب
السبب هو انه طبعا الاتحاد الافريقي من
يوم خمسه وعشرين اكتوبر 2021
بدا له يعني راي سالب في المسار العام في
السودان لانه هو اعتبر ما قام به الفريق
البرهان رئيس مجلس السياده اعتبره انقلابا
عسكريا ولوائح الاتحاد الافريقي طبعا لا
تقبل الانقلابات العسكريه ولذلك جمدت
عضويه السودان وابتعدوا
رغم ان موسى فكي يعني ظل على تواصل مع
كثير من الاطراف السودانيه لكن كانت دور
سلبي شيء اخر ما حصل في جبهه في اثيوبيا
تجاره للسودان يعني الاتحاد الافريقي كان
يرى انه المساله يعني اثارها السلبيه على
السودان تجعل موقفه كثير من الحرج
وبالتالي تراجع الدور ثم الاتحاد الافريقي
نفسه الياته لحل المشاكل الى حد كبير
التراجعت في القرن الافريقي وفي قضيه
الصومال وفي قضيه
الكونغو وفي مشاكل جنوب السودان يعني
ذكائك عليهم المشاكل بشكل كبير وبالتالي
هناك يعني ربما تراجع ملحوظ لدوره كما
تقول دكتور شكرا جزيلا لك من ابها الضمه
الينا الساده الاعلام في جامعه الملك خالد
الدكتور عوض ابراهيم عوض شكرا جزيلا لك